l'île continent sous la menace du
coronavirus alors que la deuxième ville
d'australie melbourne et de nouveaux
confiné depuis le 9 juillet dernier
l'état de victoria enregistre une
augmentation impressionnante de nouveaux
cas d'infection au covic 19
brett sutton administrateur en chef de
la santé de cet état durement touchée
appelle un changement de comportement de
la population
on ne peut pas s'attendre à ce que les
chiffres baissent automatiquement
je pense que ce sera un défi encore plus
grand dans les prochains jours cela
signifie que nous allons voir 500 à 600
nouveaux cas par jour
je ne veux surtout pas que nous en
arrivions là je veux donc renforcer tout
ce qui fera la différence et cela
correspond aux règles de base isolement
et la quarantaine des règles de base à
respecter qui s'ajoute à l'obligation du
port du masque à partir de ce jeudi les
habitants de melbourne devront porter le
masque en toute circonstance dès qu'ils
sortent de chez eux
une mesure inédite en australie qui
concerne plus de 5 millions de personnes
nous allons porter des masques dans
l'état de victoria et potentiellement
dans d'autres régions du pays pendant
très longtemps
il n'existe pas de vaccin contre ce
virus extrêmement contagieux et c'est
une chose simple mais elles demandent de
changer nos habitudes pour qu'elle
devienne un simple élément de votre
routine
la plupart d'entre nous ne sortirait pas
de chez eux sans leurs clés nous ne
sortirions pas de la maison sans votre
téléphone portable vous ne pourrez pas
sortir de chez vous sans votre masque ni
sans le porter ensuite partout il est
absolument essentiel d'arrêter la
propagation de ce virus
daniel andrews a également annoncé la
commande de 3 millions de masques 300000
sont attendus cette semaine une nouvelle
vague épidémique qui anéantit un peu
plus les espoirs d'un retour à la
normale et d'un redémarrage de
l'économie en australie